but I don't need a real tally or
anything being put on YouTube that would
be
terrific
um if there's any reason anybody has
anything to bring up before we
start seeing none so I will open the
executive session
bill8 yeah I'm not going by schedu I'm
I'm I'm doing
my I'm doing my
thing um if I can find the paperwork for
my
thing all right
um opening exact session on House Bill
118 um representative Shen moves out to
pass uh is there second second seconded
by representative verville um
representative I'm sorry turkot um would
you uh representative she would you like
to speak to your
motion yes I would thank you Mr
chair um
I would like to move
Amendment uh
08 82h
would you like to hand out
you the bill is open for further
Amendment um we have in front of
us amendment to House Bill
H representative
Shen uh yes a few weeks ago a few weeks
ago um we heard a non-gain amendment to
hb18 uh that replaced all of the bill
language and replaced it with a number
of committees and commissions to be
repealed um this new Amendment um is
basically the same um except we are not
repealing the child care
uh commission we are simply just
removing the legislative members um the
House and Senate members so that uh the
been thank you representative Shan any
uh further
conversation representative wall given
I thought try again given the discussion
that we you had before in committee and
since among members I I think this is a
good Amendment it's very much needed and
I will support it thank
you thank you representative wall any
further conversation discussion seeing
none when the clerk's ready I'll ask uh
to call the role uh we are voting um on
the utop pass as amended actually we're
voting on the amendment um uh for a to
pass only got
that Amendment
0882 H um Clerk and coloroll vice chair
chair um Chen yes represented
turot yes represent verville
yes representative Boyd yes clerk vote
Yes representative
Barton yes representative wall yes
representative Richards yes
representative py yes representative Fox
yes representative Wade yes and the
chair chair votes yes um I believe
that's unanimous uh yes 12 yay Zer n so
that means we now move to a to pass as
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk when he is ready to call the rooll
vice chair Sheen yes representative
turkot yes representative
verbil yes representative voyd yes clerk
vote Jeff representative
Barton yes representative wall yes
represent Richards yes representative P
yes representative Fox yes
representative Wade yes and the chair
chair vote Yes 12a z
consent seeing
none host Bill 1 and8 will be on
consent and I'll close the session on
118 next will be House Bill
okay opening up the executive session on
House Bill 114 representative Boyd moves
itl uh is there a second chairman you
142 House Bill
142 representative Boyd moves itl he
just panicked down there when I call the
wrong number um is there a uh second on
that itl
motion second seconded by representative
shien um representative Boyd would you
like to speak to your motion no thank
you um I will
correct a statement I made earlier about
it um I believe I was under the
impression that um the Constitution
talks about this gold star Mother's Day
um this now says that it's actually RSA
for colon
13h that does that so if we look at and
I wish I had made a copy of all of this
um lists all of the different events
that the
executive um Branch does
for
um every event you can possibly think of
um you know uh from the birthdays of all
of our um branches military branches the
governor uh does the proclamation for um
for that um also mentioned in that is
the um actual Proclamation that the
governor shall do uh for goldar Mother's
Day
um in in the um in the section that
deals with the birthdays of the uh
military branches it actually speaks to
the um uh shall have the flag flown um
over the state house or on the State
House complex so um there would be no
reason why anyone couldn't
um request a pro a similar Proclamation
from the governor and that seems to be
the correct way to handle this is to
have U the U the governor make a
proclamation of it being uh gold star
Mother's Day and um and have uh Flags
flown or whatever else uh she would like
to have done so uh rather than us
putting it um in Statue and handling it
separately um it's already in statute
but it's under the executive branch so
that seems to be the best way to do it
Is there further
conversation about yes representative W
thank you Mr chair um and given
that this already exist in statute um
the celebration of gold star Mother's
Day and the fact that there are other
days where it specifies raising the flag
would it be possible to amend this to
specify within that RSA to um raise the
flag or read or read out a proclamation
group uh thank you for your question I
assume that's to me um so uh there is
there if you read the proclamation or
the section that I mentioned
413 um it says it it encompasses all of
this um it says that the governor shall
do I should just pull it up let me just
pull it up and read exactly rather than
paraphrase um RSA
browse uh
for powers of the governor and councel
in certain
circumstances uh
13h so it says uh the governor shall
annually issue a proclamation calling
for the proper observance of the first
Sunday after Easter which is shall be
known as gold star Mother's Day
recognizing and honoring all mothers who
have lost Sons or daughters while on
duty in the United States armed forces
this is the key sentence the governor
shall urge the citizens of the state to
observe this day with appropriate events
the appropriate events I believe is is
um in that Proclamation saying all of
those things like um we're going to have
a flag raising uh over the State House
um yes uh thank you um for the comment I
think that sentence is very important
based on the testimony that we heard um
from the families that were here this is
a very special it's a special flag and
that executive order um Proclamation and
the RSA that the executive can do
can um allow this flag to be really uh
closely remembered either in towns where
it where the the governor makes that
Proclamation and really because the
interpretation of that flag it's so
special people need to get kind of up
close and have uh ceremonies to that I
feel that only in conquered is not
enough um let's make sure that the
governor puts out that Proclamation and
and in in and support those families to
utilize this already existing RSA thank
you represent representative wall thank
thank you very much first off could
someone shut that door please it's
awfully noisy I want to be
heard okay thank you very much I I
appreciate all the comments I was
unaware of that section that you found
uh Mr chairman and I appreciate that um
I I've been planning to vote for this to
be supportive of all the families who
came in here and all I I will say I come
from a military family I understand
where everyone's coming from I respect
it my I have one question how we would
get the governor to do the proclamation
but I want to
say I've witnessed over my entire life
the meaning of having Flags where people
can see them and talk about them and
gather and have a little ceremony around
them and as much as I love our state
house and I do look at the Dome every
time we go by to be perfectly truthful I
don't always look to see what flags are
up there because I guess we know what's
up there um I have asked in the past if
we couldn't have it up there if we could
have it down in the plaza there is a
flag pole there but that is reserved for
another occasion another purpose um I've
asked also if we could have at the State
library and that didn't work so giving
it a whole lot of thought and talking
with a lot of people in my area and I
come from where PE Air Force Base was in
the Navy Ard and all a lot of military
people um actually they would like to
see the flag where they could have a
little ceremony around it you know I'm
I'm going to I'm going to support um itl
thank you not because I don't want the
flag on the dome but because I want it
where the people can come closest to it
but my question Mr chairman is how do we
get this message to the governor so that
we can be sure that this happens thank
you for your question
um I saw a little word in that in that
section that said shall um so it would
seem to me the the governor shall be
doing this um it's the the word needs to
go from anyone whe whether it's the
representative that brought the the bill
to us in the first place or any one of
us um to indicate to the governor um
what what activities um would be
suggested and and then it's up to the
governor to make those those that part
of the Proclamation so as I understand
anybody can approach the government
might it make sense then if we
individually contact as well well as
have our executive counselor from our
area do that sort of thing to make sure
that this happens that's how I read the
statute yes um just so you're aware
um I think as I told you it's four colon
13h let me tell you some of the others
that are um all the other letters of the
alphabet so we have Lafayette
constitutions Day New Hampshire Pearl
Harbor Day Teacher Appreciation Day
Destroyer escort day um congenital heart
defect Awareness Day General John Stark
day uh Portsmith peace treaty day those
are some of them that the governor shall
make those proclamations so um in that
list and many more um that is where this
is listed yes Mr chairman thank you for
reading that can we be sure that our
committee report has those listed in it
so that people who really deeply want
this can understand clearly why the vote
is going the way it is I will um be
happy to provide the representative a
copy of the report so you can see
it representative Barton uh yes thank
you thank you Mr chair first of all I in
intend to vote no on
itl reading the um the uh proposed bill
it only seeks to amend RSA 3 and
includeed within RSA 3 doesn't mention
RSA 4 at all and uh in in reading the
bill I believe um it it doesn't give
anything to the government it's just
it's embodied within the statute with
those other days that are listed in RSA
3 um so and I'm okay with that so I'll
be voting no against the motion for itl
and uh the representative all does not
speak for me thank you representative h
Hello thank you um I also will be voting
no against the itl because um from the
hearing and everything it just seems to
me that if this group of individuals is
asking for recognition they should get
the recognition and so that's why I'm
going to vote against it thank you any
further
conversation seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the rooll we will be
voting um on House Bill 142 uh on the
motion of itl
Vice chair
shean
yes representa
turot yes representative bville yes
representative Boyd yes clerk votes yes
wall representative Richards
yes Representative py
no representative Fox yes representative
and the chair
to3
UM the motion passes uh HB 142 is
okay um just a second to reset and then
we'll be moving on to actually um the
non gerain
9:30
okay the time being 9:30 I'm going to
open the public hearing on the non
gerain amendment to House Bill
456 and recognize the prime sponsor
representative turot
welcome thank you Mr chairman uh members
of the committee representative Len
turkot I represent straford County
District 4 the towns of
barington and
straford um
I hope everybody has a couple of copies
in front of you the the the amendment to
456 that or that replaces it in its
entirety was originally
okay that's the one we will be basically
talking to um you will also see that
there's a
908h that's we will also discuss I
identical with the
exception of lines 11 through 7 uh 18 on
the page two and the reason for that is
I continually attempted to make sense
out of those lines on 721 and convince
myself they
were not good so I had a little bit of a
redraft done there so anyway we'll speak
to uh we'll kind of speak to both of
them as we go here um but let me just
tell you about the what we've done um
the first part on page
one of the amendment line 14 we've
changed the an annual membership
allowance from 20 up to
$75 simply done I'm guessing that hasn't
been done in a few decades so we've uh
upped that uh we also changed on line 15
the word fee to does because um
that is what these are these are dues
and to make it consistent throughout the
fees in line
18 through
22 that would prohibit any of those du's
members uh du's membership money from
being used to pay a lobbyist or lobbyist
organization it does make specifically
clear that any such member or
Association or member of Association uh
can still record a position they just
cannot have a lobbyist uh use any of
that money for a
lobbyist line 24 through
26 is uh Pro what I consider probably
the most important part of this and that
takes the money that currently goes to
the
nhma uh from a line item that sometimes
at least I know in my town is buried
deep within the um
budget and brings it out and in the case
of my town barington would require a
separate warrant article now the reason
for that of course in my estimate or my
idea is full
transparency and I'll give you a few
examples when I contacted my
administrator who is a fantastic Town
Administrator by the way um I asked him
I said what is the amount of money that
we pay to the
nhma and it was somewhere in the $9,500
range um don't quote me on that exact
number but uh for example in this last
just yesterday we had a couple warn
articles that came up in my town that
were
$5,000 and around
$10,000 so I think it's um it's worthy
of our citizens being allowed to vote on
this specific issue I want to also make
it clear that this is not an affront to
the nhma uh during my time on uh as
chairman last term of Municipal and
County um I will say I had a fairly good
actually a very good relationship with
31 talks about uh the association not
being allowed to State a definitive
position I will say that even though
that's in this it's I think
it's fair to say that somebody can still
give
testimony and if the listener is paying
attention we prob probably be able to
get a good idea of where they actually
stand on it we had in a meeting not too
long ago the Commissioner of Agriculture
I Believe come in without his uh any
kind of a card and testified as an
individual so you don't have to
necessarily make a definitive position
to get your your point AC uh point
across then the last part was what I was
talking about at the beginning and that
was
uh lines starting at a line
11 on page
two and again I I just I had to redo it
for for clarity reasons I just didn't
think uh it read very well and basically
the purpose of that is um
that you cannot
co-mingle
funds and you have to segregate them and
actually have physically uh separate
purposes so with that I hopefully I've
explained what the complete Amendment
does and certainly happy to attempt to
answer any questions thank you
representative and you will provide us a
pink card at some point absolutely thank
you um further questions representative
Wade thank you Mr chair um so in here it
it states uh I'll just do page one I
think it's in a couple places but page
one line 18 no part of the annual
membership dues shall be used to pay a
lobbyist or an organization that pays
part or all of the salary of a
lobbyist and then um it
also
states that uh pardon me one moment
uh it it it states the position of the
financial separation where funds would
have to be separated if they were used
to be paid for lobbying
purposes however if if we're
specifically referring to the New
Hampshire Municipal Association in this
in this
instance wouldn't that you know it it's
it states that they cannot be used to
pay an
organization that pays even part of the
the funding for lobbyist so wouldn't
that Encompass even if the funds were
separated it's still the New Hampshire
Municipal
organization um in in that case so my my
question is does does that prohibit the
New Hampshire Municipal Association from
paying a lobbyist even if the funds were
separated as long as the money for
paying the lobbyists is not taxpayers
money or is specifically raised for that
purpose does that make
sense
um well in in line 18 it says that no
part of the annual membership dues shall
be used to pay a lobbyist okay um or pay
an organization that pay as part of or
all of the salary of a lobbyist so it's
is that what you're saying in regards to
financial separation but if you look at
318 is Town officer associations that's
not the section of the rsas that address
24 it's odd but the nhma has their
own RSA okay within
our okay thank you representative rille
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative uh for for for taking my
question I just want to make sure I
understand that this clearly so the
intent of the the amendment is so that
tax payer derived revenue is not used
for lobbying but it does not preclude
the New Hampshire Municipal Association
from raising revenue from other sources
that they could then choose to dedicate
to lobbying it just can't be taxpayer
money is that correct I wish I could
have stated it exactly like just did but
yes that's exactly it thank you uh
follow if I may Mr chairman thank you uh
and thank you for for taking the second
question so what would you believe that
um since getting involved in in local
politics uh some 15 years ago I get
repeated complaints from constituents
that part of their local property tax
dollars that goes to the new New
Hampshire Municipal Association is used
to Lobby against their personal position
so their own money is being used to
Lobby against their their
position I would absolutely believe that
I've I've heard that um I'm not as
active as some people are in their local
uh Town boards or whatever but I've
certainly heard that yes thank you m
representative further questions
representative wall thank you very much
thank you for coming and giving this to
us today representa terot what I'm
trying to understand having been a
select in my
community how do we pay the municipal
Association our dues and figure out how
much of it goes to a lobbyist how does
the municipal Association separate every
Community because it's my understanding
from testimony that if not all almost
all communities and locations in New
Hampshire belong to the New Hampshire
Municipal Association how how do they
separate each community because I know
you you testified just now as to how
much your community pays in mine pays
just a couple hundred our dues based on
our population in our communities how do
you do
that um or how do they do it just so you
know my my hearing after 40 years in the
cockpit isn't great so I was
uh I think I heard what you were asking
um how do they separate it is that
basically let I I think it would be if I
can paraphrase how how would the
community know um whether their money is
being used for lobbying purposes um is
that what the if that's a question
that's uh when we talked about uh lines
24 for 26 that's exactly the issue I'm
trying to uh one of the issues I'm
trying to change and that would require
in your town as with mine your Madbury I
believe would require a separate War
curent
article um on the ballot so instead of
whatever your town currently pays as a
light item that's somewhere in the
budget that nobody ever sees now it
would be required to bring that out as a
warrant
article does that help or did I
not answer paraphrase you're part way
there only part part way
there um how does the municipal
association with 200 some odd people and
people um entities paying dues how do
they know how much time any lobbyist is
giving to any particular Community
because certain issues affect more some
communities more than others and they
try to take a broad spectrum as to what
is going to be most beneficial or
detrimental to a community how do they
actually do the figuring or how can
they all right let me take a look at
this again I want to make sure sure I
answer
correctly all right so on line two
through five on page two I I hope it
explain exps it there says no membership
due shall be contributed to or paid to
an organization that pays part of all
its salary of a lobbyist but nothing in
the section shall be construed to Pro
prohibit an individual public official
that's the same language that's up on
the town offices Association page and
basically um the only CH in in that
paragraph the only change we're making
is for the nhma because they do have
their own RSA is by put
the uh requirement to put basically
their pay onto the ballot how they
segregate those funds is talked about
down in 15 through 17 on there the
sources may be used for that purpose if
the other funds are not co-mingled it's
going to be up to the N
nhma uh to to figure out and have their
separate accounts um to for the to to
make sure that the funds are not
co-mingled
does that make sense no no follow up you
follow up I'm gonna just let that rest
for a minute or two or three um as it is
now any official or any
Town um person official or resident can
already come up here and
testify corre any Bill
anyway
um so even though my town for example
want to do something
that through the municipal Association
for example when we get legal advice on
water issues someone in our town may not
agree with that they can come up anyway
already and testify but you've got it in
here that that's part of your Amendment
yes that I can answer very very
specifically and the reason is we've
heard testimony on these bills
before and a matter of fact couple of
the emails that we got sent to us on
this where the the individuals have St
that's going to disallow our members
from coming up and testifying that's not
true and that why we specifically put
that in there to make that perfectly
clear so there's
no uh no question on that one we're
making it perfectly clear it doesn't
prevent I don't know what position you
hold in your town maybe nothing if
you're a selectman it does not prohibit
you from coming up here as a selectman
of your town and stating a position we
support one of the other issues I think
you Pro as a Small Town versus somebody
from say
Manchester totally two different animals
not unlike what we just went through
with our uh straford County uh
commissioner where we finally brought
our
commissioners uh into districts for the
first time because we had for the past
forever a couple of the
Cities really determining our three
Commissioners and excluding the input of
the very small um and Northern parts of
our County so I think it's kind of along
that same issue here this does not
prevent you from coming up um and
testifying and a matter of fact as I was
driving up here this morning I even
thought about maybe maybe and I'm sure
that NH nhma is not going to like this
but maybe um where there are
disagreements within when you guys all
vote in in your NH nhma
meetings maybe you guys maybe everybody
maybe the state needs to do something
similar to what we did in straford
County where we go wait a minute here
maybe there needs to be a segment of
nhma that focuses on these towns the
cities this so you can get your
different positions uh brought
before hearings you know final final
Final one final one thank you I'm going
right back to the division um of
salaries and such um we've heard
testimony from the New Hampshire
Municipal Association that how on Earth
do you
divide among all the communities and
locations cuz heart's location places
like that in the North part of the state
um how how do you know how much time a
lobbyist puts on a particular issue that
may affect more towns than others how do
you put a price tag on that I would say
that would be an excellent question for
probably somebody else who's going to
come testify against this I have no idea
thank
you thank you representative Vergo thank
you Mr chairman thank you uh
representative for for for taking my my
question as somebody who's really
reasonably uh well aware of of the the
goods and services that the New
Hampshire Municipal Association uh
provides to to
communities it it sounds to me like the
purpose of the the amendment is so that
local dues derived from taxpayer
money goes to support the New Hampshire
municiple Association activities that
are not lobbying and and by way of
example if you're not familiar with the
New Hampshire Municipal Association um
they provide legal services so um I've
been on the budget committee on and off
for over over a decade and if we have a
legal question um we can submit the
question to to New Hampshire Municipal
Association and and their attorneys on
staff you know weigh it over and they
you know they they they give you some
some opinions to help to help guide you
they provide uh training for elected
officials so if you newly get elected to
a budget committee um or a El board or a
trustee of the trust funds Etc um they
offer classes and books that go through
the rsas that are pertinent to those
offices and what your Authority is and
what your Authority is not and and and
how to operate and what you're supposed
to do and and I think the purpose and
correct me if I'm wrong because this is
my question I think the purpose of the
amendment is to allow those monies
collected from taxpayers to fund all of
those activities
but to not fund direct lobbying so that
if the if the New Hampshire Municipal
Association wants to Lobby the
legislature they have to get those funds
those revenues somewhere else so the
accounting is simple all the DU go to
non- lobbying activities and other
sources of revenue could go to lobbying
is that is that correct representative
that again perfectly stated um I would
add
that yes they the other services they
provide um again when I was M Municipal
in County last year they a lot of that
stuff was provided and worked very well
with them correct I will add the only
caveat on that would be that now that
money collected from towns for those
purpos you stated other than
lobbying would be required on an a
warrant article yeah that that part I I
understand I agree oh I'm sorry m
chairman follow up yeah on on that part
I'm crystal clear and and and agree I
think it's a great idea thank you
representative
sure any further questions
representative P thank you when we're
talking about keep using the phrase
lobbying lobbying lobbying in my
perspective when we talk about lobbying
it's we have lobbyists obviously all
over the place around here they're
always coming in they're giving opinions
okay and then we as the elected
officials take what they have to say and
then make our decision this feels like a
major overreach in micromanaging of our
towns
and why I don't understand the why of
why we're doing that if you in your own
personal Town don't have an issue with
it which I think that's the minority
then do a warrant article in your town
why are you trying to control the entire
State it's just seems very
strange excellent
question this addresses
taxpayer funded lobbying yes there are
lobbyists up here all the time I I mean
hundreds of them I don't know how many
lobbyists we have 100 maybe more most of
those are funded privately through law
firms um business industry Association
those aren't taxpayer money this
addresses taxpayers money plain and
simple so I'm a taxpayer and I don't
feel that this represents my my opinions
and positions that's my that's what I'm
trying to say is that um you know we
need to hear all perspectives this feels
greatly like a suppression of trying to
suppress different opinions and just
make it harder make it harder for cities
and towns so why not I feel like we're
trying to over micromanage our Selectmen
and our Mayors and all these elect other
elected officials that are trying to do
their job with this legislation not sure
I heard a question in there but um I
would say that well how is it not
suppressing information that's my
question I would say you and everybody
else will have the ability to
vote your perspective on this I mean
that's what it comes down to I mean
we're going to vote here in the
committee it's going to go to the house
floor if it passes it's going to go to
the Senate it's going to go to the
governor's nest and if everything passes
then your town you will still be be able
to vote whether or not to
um give money to the um nhma or whatever
so and so can you oh I'm
sorry follow up yes it is thank you can
you specify exactly which lines relate
to a town doing a Warren article in here
yeah uh line 25 it talks about the
legislative body uh in a in most towns
that would be through the Warren article
I'm not an expert on cities I believe
that would be through the council but um
I know in towns it's it's through the
Warren article process I'm sure I don't
know where you're from representative
but like I say yesterday on our ballot
we probably
had 20 25 warrant articles ranging from
a low of $5,000 up to $100,000
individuals warn articles that our
Town's citizens voted on U and I will
say unfortunately every one of them
passed but I mean that's
um I guess my
answer thank you does this Amendment
affect other associations or is this
specific to
nhma um it it affects the town Officers
okay thank you representative wall
another shot at it another shot at thank
you Mr chairman thank you very much for
being here can you hear me okay I'll
keep it closer thank you um based on
questions we've just had um I we vot
most of us have just come through town
meeting and we voted last night on our
budget for the year ahead um State runs
on a different fiscal year from the way
we do we don't know what issues are
going to come up from year to year that
affect our communities that the New
Hampshire Municipal Association will be
working on how on Earth does a community
budget an appropriate sum of money for a
lobbyist not knowing what kind of hours
may have to go into it for the year
ahead when we have no idea what bills
are coming up how much time we'll have
to go into it what communities are
affected I I I can't see how we can
develop a formula for that
not are you saying that mad Berry now
will have to hire its own
lobbyist I I'm not maybe I don't
understand the question um we are my
community and the communities I
represent um our members of the New
Hampshire Municipal Association if we
have to separate from that and hire a
lobbyist we can't possibly project
what's going to be happening and that
type of instance for what bills are
coming up how many bills how few the
municipal Association sometimes has a
whole lot of bills before the
legislature how does anybody develop a
formula for that I'm not sure if formula
is needed is isn't the enemy isn't your
dues already based
on uh the population of your
town okay if the dues for the municipal
Association are based on the population
you are correct in that um but that's
the dues but you want to separate the
lobbyists out from that is that
correct we want to separate the funds
used for lobbying out from that correct
and then put it through a Warren article
that's correct thank you Mr chairman and
thank you and that's where I'm going
with it you separate the lobbyist out
from what we're paying from our legal
advice and this that and the other from
the municipal Association but if again
we have no idea what bills will be
coming up we have no idea what the
lobbyist may need to put in for hours or
what it's going to cost I I can't see
how this is workable thank you I I
believe we heard last week or last time
we had a meeting in this
uh hearing on a similar bill that the
nh's
um budget is $2.3
million something tells me that they
would have the ability to do what you're
this will be the
last Point uh representative Ville thank
you Mr chairman thank you representative
for taking my question is there anything
in the proposed
amendment that prohibits the New
Hampshire Municipal
Association from track tracking
legislation being proposed in in the
legislature and notifying communities of
bills that they believe May or may you
know may be of interest to particular
communi so that they are aware of what
the legislature is proposing is there
anything in this bill that proh
prohibits them from tracking that and
notifying communities of of legislation
pending legislation absolutely not thank
you representative okay thank you very
much for testifying we're move on to uh
some new ideas and questions I'm sure uh
the chair will call Representative Alvin
C
has asked for two minutes uh
representing maram County and opposes
the
Bill thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee I'm Al representative
Alvin C uh represent lden and seven
other towns in a float teral District
I'm uh opposed to this when I went to uh
vote yesterday after I voted I was
called as sign by uh the fire chief and
he was uh really up at Arms about about
this bill
because and he says this amendment makes
it worse and after reading it I think it
does the U problem comes from the fact
that the uh towns and cities pay to join
either nhma or other groups so that they
can have
somebody to review the nearly th000
bills we do every year and see which
ones have an effect on on their group
and there are several different groups
he is involved with fire issues he knows
he can come in here on his own and
testify but while he's here then he's
not available to respond on emergency
calls should there be
any and his concern is that he wants
somebody to be able to speak for him and
say whether or not they f a bill um
particularly on the uh the original Bill
where it says uh providing information
shall not include promoting or opposing
or directly directly or indirectly any
legislation and just the nature of of uh
legislation it makes it very difficult
to provide a statement that does
not uh provide some indication of how
you stand on a bill whether you're in
favor it or not and in particular if
there are major
issues um so that said it's just a
matter of
uh while the town is paying money for
joining these
organizations there is a purpose for
them joining the organizations and they
want that help and that includes sending
a lobbyist to come visit us or any of
the Committees to speak on behalf of the
members of the of that group thank you
and I'll take questions if there are
any thank you representative verville
thank you Mr chairman thank you for for
coming and taking my
question would you believe that it would
be possible that there would be an issue
topic X in which uh the members of a
community were divided on uh agree or
disagree say on a on a 6040 split
so 60% of the residents of a community
think it's a a good idea and and 40%
think it's a bad idea and so if the
taxpayer money is used to lobby for the
60% then the tax the taxes collected
from 40% of the population are now being
used against their interest would you
would you agree that that's that's
possible that's possible yes thank you
and it's one of those things where um
just about every issue that comes to a
town there's some people who are opposed
to it and some people are in favor of it
how the mix is whether 6040 or some
other followup so I don't disagree with
that the difference is at the local
level they're not hiring a lobbyist to
to get something done right it's the
communities aren't always 100% unified
but do do you think it's appropriate
that you use taxpayer money against the
interest of the taxpayer that that that
provided the cash uh not completely on
that and uh what I'll say on that
is while that is an issue I don't think
this bill or this
amendment corrects that in a suitable
way thank you Mr chairman thank you
further questions your
microphone um I have one um in your
community representative does uh does
your community vote on uh
individually or separately on your um
fire district or your town uh
purchasing um services from the um the
fire chiefs Association
or uh no it's all lumped into one
budget I can understand the part in here
of separating that out so that the
voters of the town can see what part of
their budget that is going to uh these
organizations for
lobbying uh thank you so um if I can
paraphrase then you are saying you're
okay with um an individual vote by the
town whether to have the services or
not that might be a useful thing and I
think that might be a good idea for a
new uh legislation for next year to uh
bring the idea
up uh thank you if you if you had that
vote um
or what would be the significant
difference between um
deciding whether to uh contribute with
taxpayer money to that organization or
not
what what changes from this bill to what
Bill the the main part in here and what
the uh people at least in my town say is
that it's uh preventing them from
speaking or preventing them from saying
actually what they think will help or
hinder them in terms of what the
legislation
is uh thank you but you are aware on
whatever line it was that said anyone
can speak
at any time in existing law and it's
reinforced here that nothing in this
section shall be construed to prohibit
any individual member from an
association from recording a position
before the general court or
committee yes I saw that and for my fire
chief he doesn't live that far away lden
is not right next to conquered so he
could get here but even still the
several hours that he would have to be
away from town he's not available for
his job in town but there are people
much further away than lden I see thank
you um I'm gonna pass this over to you
thank you for your testimony uh no
further questions thank
I call
bines
Burns good morning welcome to ledge
admin good morning thank you so much um
my name is Margaret Burns I'm the
executive director of the New Hampshire
Municipal Association and we are here
this morning in opposition to the
non-german amendment to house bille
456 the conversation this morning has
been a a little confusing I'm going to
speak to my understanding of the bill um
try to address some of the um items that
have been raised here this morning and
am absolutely happy to take questions as
well at the end this morning a lot of
the conversation has been around the New
Hampshire Municipal Association as is
typically the case with bills like this
that are filed year after year um but
it's important to understand that this
bill affects a lot more than just the
New Hampshire Municipal Association
there are many or organizations in the
state of New Hampshire that represent
different groups of local officials that
collect dues to perform the functions
that they have and these organizations
typically Pro provide an array of
services right so they typically provide
both the education side and they do some
level of advocacy at the state
legislature some of these associations
Advocate on their own behalf so perhaps
their president is the advocate of the
association but many others higher
outside lobbyists um nhma and
organizations structured more similar to
us we have in-house lobbyists who are
employees of the association who are
typically individuals who have expertise
in Municipal issues so that we are both
able to Advocate and to provide the
other services that the members um need
so for example I'm a lawyer I've been
within New Hampshire Municipal
Association for over a decade I have the
ability to serve as an advocate I have
the ability to provide Prov legal advice
and guidance to members as well as to
run the
association the way that I read this
bill is it really does two things it
prohibits three specific Statewide
organizations representing local
officials from taking positions on
legislation it separately puts new
restrictions on all the other
associations that are not listed in 318
and
318a puts new restrictions on them that
prohibit them from
lobbying with public funds which for
those
associations may be all of the funds
that they receive or collect so I can't
I I won't speak for other associations
but to the extent that the majority of
their funding comes from public funds
that are paid by the municipalities or
the local officials who members of that
Association that prohibition or that new
restriction created in the amendment at
the end on page two could entirely
prohibit them from any kind of advocacy
activity on their behalf or on that
association's behalf so I'll let them
speak to that but it's a pretty Broad
associations so with respect to NH
the new language proposed to
318a would prohibit us from taking a
position on
legislation but I also heard when the
bill was
introduced that because we could still
provide information to the
legislature legislators could sort of
read between the lines to know what
position we are EX ing when we're
speaking to that
legislation I struggle to understand
then why the prohibition on taking a
position is necessary if we can come
here and provide the information as we
already do on behalf of our members then
why the ban on speech why the ban on two
words oppose and support if it's clear
from the information we're providing
that that's the position that we're
taking
the bill would also then override Our
member adopted policies so I've spoken
to this committee before about how every
two years nhma has a member driven
legislative policy process our members
serve on policy committees they review
our legislative policies they ultimately
meet in a town meeting style group they
vote by a super majority whether to
adopt the policies proposed or whether
to make amendments whether to strike Etc
and so by prohibiting us from taking a
position this would be the state
legislator legislature overriding a
local organization's process for taking
positions on
legislation another aspect of what this
amendment does is instead of allowing
nhma which again is a private
independent
organization instead of allowing us to
represent our members at the legislature
we become more of an instrumentality of
the state we're restricted to providing
information but we can't do what we've
been sent here by our members to do
which is to take positions on
legislation and to explain why we have
those positions why we have the um the
great interest in the legislation why
it's positive why it's not what the
concerns are so that is a deep concern
about what the amendment to 318a does as
to the seg ation of funds I've already
spoken to how that could be a complete
ban on advocacy for many of these
organizations who are 100% or perhaps
primarily funded by public funds through
their
dues if there is a transparency argument
here um a transparency argument with
respect to the use of public funds I
would say two
things one the provision in and I'm
looking at I suppose they're the same
lines I'm looking at at the new
amendment I saw this morning so the
0908 looking at the new the language in
20 line 25 and 26 at the bottom of the
page that language doesn't change
anything municipalities already have an
obligation or legislative bodies are
already required to appropriate the
money to pay these dues whether they're
in the budget or in a separate warrant
article the vote to approve is an
appropriation by the legisl
body some towns already have separate
warrant articles for nh's dues it's
always been their right to do that
individual voters 25 or more can
petition to put it on the warrant and
make it a separate warrant article
that's been done as well there is
absolutely nothing prohibiting
municipalities from doing it that
way the other thing that I would mention
two other things that I would mention
just last year this committee
recommended a bill that would require
the Secretary of State's office to have
digital and online filing process for
lobbyist reporting and that bill was
signed into law by the governor so if
there's concerns about increased
transparency for the amount of funds
that are being used to Lobby that bill
is actually going to help with increased
transparency because nhma already
reports the amount of money that we
spend on lobbying it's they're already
publicly available reports that anyone
can look up and pull but but when that
digital reporting goes through I think
transparency will be even more improved
and I'm not just talking about nhma I
think it will be improved for lobbying
and general the final point I want to
make is I think we
have a bit of a red herring with the
argument that only in the situation of
organizations like nhma are public funds
being used to Lobby the reality is there
are many private sector organizations
and entities that are part of Municipal
and state budgets they receive taxpayer
funds energy companies law uh lawyers
firms other private entities that
receive taxpayers funds all the time and
they would not be restricted in any way
by this legislation they would not be
touched in any way by this legislation
so they would have no further
restrictions on their lobbying but nhma
and similar groups would have
restrictions on their
lobbying for these reasons NH as opposed
to the legislation I even thought to
myself when I read the bill that one of
the Curious results of this legislation
would be that if nhma was no longer
lobbying under RSA chapter 15 and we
were only providing information there
would actually be less public reporting
because we would no longer be filing our
public lobbying reports with the
Secretary of State we would no longer
fall under that statute which seems to
be an odd consequence of legislation
that so often has been surrounded by
conversations about transparency and use
of public funds so for these reasons
nhma is opposed to the bill we're
opposed to how it affects our
organization we're opposed to how it
affects the members we're opposed to how
it affects similarly situated
organizations who Advocate on their
members behalfs thank
you thank you for your testimony are
there any
questions that here thank you for coming
in and giving that concise summary
question I think I heard you say this
that even if a town did a warrant
article to pay their dues that wouldn't
matter the bill still wouldn't allow the
activities is that correct so even if so
if this if this
318a once our dues were appropriated by
that
municipality we still would only Beed ow
to provide information to the
legislature not to
Lobby So when you say oh sorry can I do
a okay when you say provide information
what did that what would that look like
you would come in and give information
but you wouldn't you couldn't say oppose
or against is that what you're
saying it's unclear and I think that our
staff would be concerned about being
accused
of taking positions so for
example I'm here
today saying that I oppose the amendment
to House Bill
456 under this bill I couldn't say that
but if I listed out all the reasons that
the bill is negative and hurts
municipalities will I be accused of
lobbying of taking a position of
influencing a vote because of course
when I express serious concerns about a
piece of legislation
I am indeed influencing a vote and I'm
doing it transparently there's nothing
hidden about it but could that be
construed to be illegal lobbying under
the bill I don't know and when we pass
legislation that is unclear to the
extent at which speech is prohibited or
allowed we chill speech and I would
suggest that that is very disturbing
especially in the context of a
legislative
process PA up thank you um so the other
thing heard you say it sounds like if
this legislation were to pass nonprofits
such as yourself and other groups
firefighters Association Police
Association whatnot which I believe are
nonprofits would be suppressed but
for-profit entities law firms those
sorts of things would not be affected by
Okay re Wade uh thank you uh for taking
my question um so you you had mentioned
that uh a lot of towns and these these
smaller
organizations get all or vast majority
of their funds from state and local and
and dues like that so are there any
funds that nhma or these organizations
get that are not state or local I won't
speak for other organizations I will let
them speak for themselves nhma does have
some other funds that come through
sponsorships that would not
constitute local funds
um we do also have some other services
that have an extra fee on them but those
are paid by local
funds so it's a little unclear under
this amendment whether those would also
be funds that could not be used for
lobbying activity follow up um could you
give an approximate percentage of how
much of the budget comes from the dues
and how much might come from those kinds
of sponsorships I believe and I don't
like to speak off the top of my head so
I'm so I'm giving you estimates based on
um what I what I recall I believe about
70% of our budget is dues but then
another portion of the remaining 30
would include some of the trainings and
other events that we charge an extra fee
for which would be local funds um so
it's only a small portion at the end of
the day that would you could call
so-called private sector
funds last follow up last follow up um
so would it be fair to say that in the
event that you were not able to use any
of those dues on uh payments for
lobbying that you would just be unable
to afford uh lobbyists yes and I I think
the biggest problem with this idea of
we'll just segregate out certain funds
for lobbying purposes you know segregate
out those so-called private sector funds
from the public sector funds the biggest
problem with that and I've said this
before in this committee is that we do
not know how much will be spent on
lobbying until after the at until the
end of a quarter right so I'm sure this
committee is aware that the way it works
is that you register annually with the
Secretary of State's office as a
lobbyist and then at the end of each
quarter you file a report that details
your revenues and expenses related to
lobbying so this idea that we could
segregate ahead of time the correct
amount of money when we don't know how
much time is going to be spent
throughout the session at the
legislature it's it's really not
practical and I think it sets us up for
violating the law inadvertently trying
to do it correctly but not knowing what
amount of funds will be spent on on
actual lobbying and that's deeply
problematic and that could also serve to
affect whether the association or other
associations can Lobby because they'll
have concerns about violating the
law rip
verbal thank you madam chair thank you
for coming and and and taking my my
question uh I'm going to assume that you
you heard some of my hypotheticals
earlier of a a 6040 split you know I can
imagine another hypothetical where um a
community is in favor of a particular
piece of legislation for whatever reason
and I can imagine that another Community
um would be opposed to it right so so
you've got a community a that's that's
for Community B that's against but the
association can only take one position
and so if a super majority takes a
position then you're using taxpayer
money to Lobby against their their
position position and in fact it could
be an entire community so doesn't that
become compelled speech with tax faay
taxpayer funds right once I pay my dues
and you take a a position opposite of my
community's will isn't that compelled
speech against my will no I thank you
for that question our members understand
that when nhma lobbies at the
legislature we represent the New
Hampshire Municipal Association and they
understand that they as members Direct
the course of what the municipal
Association lobbies on through their
voting at our legislative policy
conference so and because they are local
officials they also have a deep
appreciation for the fact that in a
democratic process the majority rules as
far as what positions are taken or what
outcomes occur as part of the voting
process so no I do not see that issue in
the way that you've described we do at
times have indiv idual members have
their own individual positions on
specific legislation that's never been
an issue for the association it's never
been an issue for our relationship with
the members and we encourage them if
they have a different position or if
they have any position including on
legislation that doesn't fall within
nh's purview to Advocate on we encourage
them to come out and express their
position regardless of whether it
coincides with nh's position because we
believe that's their right to do that
and that more advocacy and more input is
better than less so no I I don't agree
with that categorization and our members
absolutely know that membership with the
municipal Association is voluntary and
if that they had a true and fundamental
disagreement with the association and
the direction that we take that they
would have the ability to Simply leave
the municipal Association follow up if I
may thank you madam chair and and thank
you for taking my my second question
because it and and it's not the question
I intend to ask but but you really you
brought something to light um to to
light for
me the the challenge is the dues is an
all-in number so would you believe that
I have a a majority of constituents that
love the New Hampshire Municipal
Association the legal advice for the
training
Etc but yet I have a significant amount
of constituents that don't like the law
lobbying but it's all or none right they
can't they can't choose to divorce
themselves from the lobbying so if they
want the carrot they have to take the
stick um and and so that I guess that's
I guess that's the disconnect with how I
perceive it I I apologize it's not
really it's not really a question um I I
I guess I don't have a good form of a
question but that that's sort of where
I'm come and if you want to address that
I you know holistically that it'd be
fine thank you I think also say two
things to that one is that I believe
there is a fundamental misunderstanding
at times between what nhma lobbies on
and what people perceive us to Lobby on
I know that I've said this this in this
committee before but I will say it again
the majority of our advocacy does one of
two things it argues against pushing
more cost down on taxpayers and it
argues against taking away the power
power of Voters at the local level right
so zoning mandates is one of the big
things we Lobby against and really at
its core that's a voter rights issue
that's a a argument to not take away the
ability of Voters to have their voice so
that's one thing I would say in response
to
that my other response is that as
recently as last year this legislature
was a member of the National Council of
state
legislatures that organiz ation lobbies
at the federal level for state
legislator who are its members and I am
certain that every single constituent in
the state of New Hampshire doesn't
personally agree with every position
that that organization takes but the
legislature as the elected officials who
represent them believe that it's in
their interest to be a part of this
organization and that it does more good
than bad for you in your position as a
elected officials and that's a similar
corollary to nh's representation of
cities and towns in New Hampshire at
legislature thank you madam chair RI
Martin uh thank you madam chair very
simple question for you um are you aware
of any existing statutes that would
otherwise restrict speech even if it was
limited to taking a position on a bill
by lobbyist or an individual any other
statutes that restrict so certain just
restrict in general speech by other
lobbyists that would restrict um any any
speech that you would give testimony
we'll say specifically for position I'm
neither seeing no other questions thank
just to catch everyone up uh we have
three pink cards um I would ask we will
hear from all three um they've asked for
two minutes three minutes and three
minutes I am going to ask that uh we try
to keep questions uh to a minimum Andor
try to um make sure that our speakers
speak to ground that hasn't been trod on
um already um even if it's just standing
and saying I I concur um but uh I had
dedicated about an hour for this we've
gone the hour uh and I'd like unless we
want to jump into the afternoon here I
I'd like to move along but uh with that
I will call uh Kathy Stacy uh from New
Hampshire Association of
counties welcome to legislative
Administration
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Kathy Stacy I am
the President of the New Hampshire
Association of counties and the
Rockingham County Register of Deeds
obviously I do concur with the uh
testimony that uh nhma just provided and
I'll just say that I do represent one of
the associations that would be affected
by this amendment uh we do uh Lobby we I
represent uh 10 counties and our our
issue obviously is if we do not have a
lobbyist representing our
organization we would have 10 separate
counties with individuals from those
counties having to come here to testify
on legislation which really is not
economically feasible it really isn't a
good way to spend taxpayer dollars you
know we you know obviously there's over
a th bills we do have a legislative
committee that meets every Friday we go
over all bills and we determine you know
positions that we're going to take
there's 89 members um and and obviously
we take very seriously what's happening
here in conquer and I think that uh we
are best served obviously by having a
lobbyist and we do have dues and it's
part of the county budget and I'm sure
all of you are aware because you're all
members of your county budget your
county delegation right so you're voting
the budget and you rely upon the
subcommittees that are are uh developed
by your uh executive committee and the
delegation chair and those are the
Committees that review what's happening
with the budget and um I I just would
just say that you know we do have
education advocacy we do do sponsorships
50% um of our sponsorships pay for um
lobbying 50% of that and um you know we
have Affiliates which you know obviously
every every County department whether
it's the nursing home which is one of
the biggest departments and the most
costly for the county and there's a lot
of legislation affecting that we come up
here because we want to protect the
taxpayers of our counties from push back
from you know whether it's reduction in
fees uh in you know in in increased fees
um and we think that we do a pretty good
job at that but this bill would not
permit us to do that we would not be
able to have a lobbyist which would mean
you would be
seeing could be 10 correction uh super
tants it could be 10 nursing home of you
know um um supervisors it just it it
would and as you say yourself we don't
want to hear redundancy in in testimony
but obviously everybody would be coming
down because they would have to testify
to make sure they're protecting their
their taxpayers in their particular
County so we do oppose this bill and we
ask you to take that into
consideration thank you uh thanks for
keeping to your time limit um are there
any
questions I have a quick one um you you
have the um the Friday morning meeting I
think you said or the correct yeah um if
there is a county or two that uh chooses
not to agree with uh the consensus I
guess of of what to Lobby or what
position to take what happens then in
the past when we've had counties that
have had their own individual issues we
have not participated we have determined
that we are not going to come here in
lobby they can come and they can testify
themselves that's how we that's how our
organization handles it so it is a
unanimous decision or no decision yes
okay thank you very much thank
you seeing
none uh chair will call Dennis
Shanahan
nhma this you m
example of trotting over previous
testimony if they're representing in as
exactly uh and I will avoid that I did
provide some written testimony uh that
has similar uh similar thoughts as what
you've heard so far what I would like to
do in my very brief time is to provide a
perspective as an elected official uh on
uh on what the nhma does and how it does
it uh there's been a quite a bit of
discussion about uh under this amendment
who can sit in front of you and express
an opinion uh with a a statement that
well any elected official or appointed
official can come up specifically and
provide their opinion on it uh and I
just like to kind of run through what
the DOA city council looks like uh we've
got nine members uh we've got a project
developer and a consultant with three
schoolage kids a production manager with
school age children full-time package
handler you should see here during the
Christmas season uh school age children
uh a professor lecturer a small business
owner with children a retired department
head from the shipyard and independent
contractor specializing in finished
carpentry an IT consultant a local
business owner who trains International
Gymnastics overseas uh and a retired
teacher so you think of that group
there's only a couple of us who can do
this and and I do
this fairly frequently
um the others though they don't really
have the opportunity to be able to come
up and deal with the Thousand to 2,000
bills to even be able to digest them uh
and work their way through it so I think
it really is a to consider you can
simply replace uh the the the lobbyists
that come from the nhma with the
individual elected officials coming up
here never mind appointed officials I
kind of want my city manager to spend
his time down at his desk fixing things
getting the road clear dealing with uh
turmoil that's coming down from from
DC so that's kind of the the the how
it's very difficult for a group of
elected officials so what is it we do to
make sure that we're representing the
will of the people when we're sitting
here in front of you uh there's been a
discussion about uh uh how we get to our
policies and I want to focus on that a
little bit so the DOA city council
reviews and aligns itself with the
policies and principles that guide the
work of the
nhma we put in a resolution in front of
the city council saying here's the
policies and
principles let's endorse them and in
some cases Sometimes some of those are
removed from endorsement and therefore
as their representative very careful to
go up and make sure that I don't uh
provide any endorsements to the ones
that the council has already turned down
very few of those the council adopts a
vast majority of the policies and
principles the development of those
policies and principles obviously
includes uh the the members and
representatives of the nhma uh there are
three different Committees of uh at
least a dozen people when their work is
done over the course of the summer every
other year uh policy conference is
conven
and every member all 234 members or more
uh are are invited to come in and be a
delegate and to vote on and pass these
policies and principles this is coming
from the bottom up I feel when I sit in
front of a group that I am speaking for
my constituents I do recognize that many
of our decisions that we make don't have
unanimous support that there is a 6040 a
7030 we're going to work on a budget and
vote on in the next couple of weeks and
I can tell you that the the citizenry
are split there's a 51% and a 49% pro
and con that's how we do representative
democracy to allow the representatives
to come up in front of a a group like
yourself and bring the voice of the
people with it so the this allows the
opinions and perspectives of our
citizens to flow through our elected
officials and it gives a clear mandate
to nhma and what to speak for as the
voice so in the end when we appear in
front of it we are we are bringing the
the will and the input of our
constituents with it and an interference
to that would be removing the the the
ability of nhma uh to speak for the
people so bottom
line I'll paraphrase this as the nhma is
a lobbying organization they represent a
special interest group that special
interest group are the citizens of New
Hampshire it's us all of us are
represented by the nhma we may not
always agree with every policy and
principle but the process gets us to a
point where those are overwhelmingly
accepted uh by the folks that uh that
have an impact on it uh so with that
I'll conclude my comments address any
questions and again thank you for
listening to my testimony this morning
thank you uh representative Wade has her
hand
raised thank you Mr chair and thank you
for coming today um as a as a fellow
elected rep from do um appreciate your
time and I got to complain to you about
that new corks crew sidewalk off of
Portland avator um I was the first to to
bring that to the city manager's
attention I appreciate it the engineer
has a plan to help work on that gotcha
we can move along good to know um do you
mind just describing the uh the
challenges it took for you to come here
today as an individual as opposed to a
lobbyist um well I'm one of the
fortunate ones the retired guy uh so I
my schedule can be pretty open and uh it
has filled up quite a bit in the last
couple years and in fact just to make
sure for for due diligence and
transparency I was fortunate enough to
be uh elected as the chair of the nhma
uh board of directors you know in
addition to being the chair of uh of the
the coast board of directors uh so for
me it's it's not that much of a
challenge hence I take every opportunity
I can uh I think of council Lindsay
Williams uh the the professor lecturer
two kids small business owner uh
definitely a struggle for her to
consistently be able to to come up here
and speak to us and I feel that the
process that the nhma has in place very
well represents her interest as the is
represented the will of the
people thank you um any further
questions seeing none thank you very
much uh last pink card I have uh is for
Dave Karin um I hope that's right or
Karan um
asking for two three minutes and opposes
the
bill you
[Music]
Mr thank you Mr chairman uh good morning
committee my name is Dave Karen the Town
Administrator for the town of dairy and
also on the board of directors ofn New
Hampshire minicipal Association I
submitted testimony to you last evening
I will not repeat that but uh just to
summarize and try to provide some
additional Clarity uh I've been a Town
Administrator in the state for 44 years
and during various stents I've been on
the nhma board of directors for over 20
it's been my experience we've never had
a concern from a governing body of a New
Hampshire municipality questioning the
propriety of lobbying because that's one
of the main Services we request and
itate to perform on our behalf and it's
very important to think back to the
process with both Margaret and Dennis
said we are a democratic process we have
a legislative policy Conference of which
any member which are all 234 communities
in the state are members in h they can
participate in that process to determine
what the legislative positions will be
our attendance there is about 80 it's
onethird of our membership and seeing
through various Town meetings I I put
that participation rate against any town
meeting in the state how do we get to
those recommendations which those 234
communities can't have an opportunity to
voice on is that we have three separate
committees so like like budget
committees that look at different areas
General
Administration uh finance and then we
have environmental policies all those
are 60 people one quarter of our
association participates in that process
so you can see it's a very Democratic
process so I don't want to make Margaret
use a word salad but when when nhma
comes up here they say NH May opposes
the bill what they actually are saying
is that NH May on behalf of the director
of our 234 towns and cities oppose or
support this bill now you have the rest
of my testimony but I must confess some
confusion regarding lobbyists what I
understand from the testimony today is
that if nhma comes up here and doesn't
State a position on a bill but either
Advocates or exols the virtues of a bill
or wants the consequences but doesn't
actually say they for oppose then I
presume that's not to be lobbying well
extoling the virtues or warning the
consequences without stating a clear
position is essentially a distinction
without a
difference we pay these people to
represent us I love you guys but I can't
be here every day of the week that's why
we collectively subscribe to nhma the
dairy Town Council has been a member
forever to make sure they carry through
our policies voting on so hear Municipal
voices this legislation does not place a
gag order on municipalities to testify
but that's the Practical implication
because we have work to do at home I've
got a $55 million Municipal Corporation
with 250 employees to manage and I or my
nor my staff we can't be here every day
about these issues
so respectfully this is the wrong venue
if you believe that your citizens are
not well served by nhma they should be
speaking with their governing bodies and
advocating for the governing bodies not
included in their budget this seems to
be a lot of very respectfully this seems
to be a lot of legislative
gymnastics to address an issue which is
not an issue finally if you go back to
the original legislation which was
crafted by the state legislature 64
years ago it already put guard rails on
nh's advocacy before leg ISL is very
clear they can only advocate for
municipal issues those are the god rails
so by clear inference to me is that the
legislature 65 years ago saw the value
of that dialogue and information sharing
so again I don't think this bill is
necessary and I would uh respectfully
request that you uh vote HB 456 as
inexpedient to legislate have to answer
any questions are there any questions
any brief questions I have one brief
question um would it be your opinion
that um the majority of the 234 cities
and towns uh rely exclusively on uh nhma
or or some organization to provide them
um the information of What legislation
is uh coming that affects them I say in
in most part it uh most of of our
communities rely upon nhma for that
information we receive a legal bulletin
every Friday which is mailed to all
local officials which explains the bills
of Municipal interest the impacts of
those and the position that nhma has
been directed to take by its legislative
policy conference you know there's been
a previous question about how do you you
know if you have some communities that
are for or some against how do you
handle that a perfect example some of
you folks may remember education funding
the donor receiver communities I mean we
were split right down the middle as far
as some communities would benefit and it
would cost other communities on under
that legislation everybody knew our
members knew and understood that nhma
could not take a position on that
particular legislation because it would
impact our members in to various degrees
both in a positive way and a negative
way last question for me is is that
bulletin available to anyone or just to
it thank you any further questions
seeing none thank you very much for
coming here appreciate it uh I have no
more pink cards um I am closing the
hearing on um whatever the number is
1576 that's turot
that's
two um okay so now we're done we're
moved out of the um out of the public
hearing um for that bill we are going to
then jump back into the executive
session mode um we are now down to three
314 I believe anyone want to disagree
with
that um Mr chair oh 314 we've already
done uh that was retained in a
prior in a prior session
315 um and I will recognize uh um
representative Shen um who moves itl so
I'm looking for a second to um the itl
motion for house Bill
second seconded by uh representative
handout
way I got a one and that goes that
way um what you will be getting or have
in front of you um is a complaint
process uh
relative to the truthfulness in
testimony um and this came out of the
speaker's office as you can see on the
first line um I'll just read the
last uh well I guess it's the last
paragraph uh the speaker's office will
review the complaint and correspond with
the complaintant if more complete
information is necessary the speaker
office will evaluate the unique facts
and circumstances around each complaint
determine whether the complaint is
actionable and develop a method to
address
it that would seem to uh take
the um
steam out of um out of house bill
315 um but I just wanted it it seemed to
me that not many people were aware of
this process so I wanted to make sure
that was in front of it anyone um is
there any further discussion on House
Bill
315 crickets um so I will ask the clerk
to call the role on the motion of itl on
315 when he is
ready please Cher Sheen yes yes
representative turot yes representative
verville yes representative Boyd yes
clerk votes yes representative Barton
yes representative
wall representative Richards yes
representative py yes representative Fox
yes representative Wade yes and the
chair chair votes yes 12 y Zer
n anyone have OB to consent
see none um
up 315 will'll be on consent at
one
second
js on uh the itail motion of House Bill
157 representative turot thank you Mr
chairman
um I'll try to keep it very brief just a
few points on it and most of these
points I've already gone over with the
prime sponsor U prior um I I I think
the I think the concept of what they're
trying to get at is actually good um I
think more detailed fiscal analysis also
would be uh very very commendable but uh
it's just unworkable for a lot of
reasons and I'll give you those reasons
first it's just the amount of time that
would be required to produce these uh
extremely detailed notes uh most likely
would also require additional Manpower
which would also incur um of course more
costs and it because of the time
required to do this it probably impact
the legislative
is as you what we get now is and I'm
going to agree with the prime sponsor
and co-sponsors that what we get now is
sometimes questionable at best it's very
on a microscopic level m a microeconomic
level the problem is is when you
start expanding out from the micro to
the macro level you start introducing
subjectivity into the analysis and the
further you get and the more
uh macro you
get that analysis can go either way way
and I would even say that it could go
either way based on political leanings
so um the last the last part of the the
reason or the last thing that I would
say is I I believe again the concept is
good and as I told the prime sponsor
there's a lot of lot of good names on
here and instead of forming yet another
study committee why not get together
with the individuals on this
list spend some time and see what you
can come up with uh something that is
better than establishing a study
committee I I think it's I think it's
going to be a an exercise in futility
but at least give it a try for those
people who are
um interested in doing it I see a lot of
names from uh Ways and Means on here and
so I I think that would be the way to go
and for all those reasons I
I stand by the U inexpedient to
legislate thank you representative
turkot um the bill is open for further
Amendment and um and I have in front of
me an
amendment um from the prime sponsor at
at all um and it is
62h I'm hoping everyone has a copy of
that um and I would recognize um
representative payer for uh summarizing
perhaps yes thank you thank you Mr chair
um so representative muns who's in the
room brought the amendment forward to
make it easier um and Consolidated the
members to make it more
concise um and also kind of limited the
duties so that it addressed the concerns
that were brought up in committee um
when we first discussed this bill so
this amendment makes it more um
streamlined and less cumbersome to
address some of those
concerns thank you
um I don't uh
disagree with the amendment
um however it doesn't change my opinion
of the itl motion and and for this
reason I'm not sure you could
amend my biggest concern which is given
our time constraints we have a twoyear
twoyear
term um and we have numerous deadlines
along the way
I've this this is not the first time
this conversation has been had um just
so everyone knows and I'm sure
representative wall can back me up on
that the fact that we could have um a
deeper dive uh for lack of a better term
but um but it's awfully hard to do I
think he our our secretary uh no our
house clerk mentioned one that uh was
recently done in Commerce as I recall um
that was an eight-month process trying
to fit eight months into our two-year
legislative term inter
uh posing all of our deadlines in the
same time makes
it damn near impossible so I'm I'd be
perfectly happy listening to suggestions
of how that can be done within our time
frame I think um in conversations I've
had recently with um prior members prior
directors of os um and
LBA
um they would be willing to discuss
possibilities of how to do this
certainly not for you know a thousand
bills but but perhaps for the two or
three or four that we're that we're um
generally thinking of um but um but even
if
we were to retain this and talk about it
within committee it's not going to come
out until next uh January and and then
you're and by the time it then passes
the Senate um and is signed by the
governor presumably we're giving a very
small little window for that type of De
deep dive discussion um as a as a
committee as a study
committee my better suggestion I think I
follow along with representative turot
that um I'm a much bigger fan of ad hoc
committees um you know what you want to
talk about you know the people you want
to have in that study committee do it
now um why wait for that whole big
scenario to keep going by and come back
with a bill rather than a study
committee um
there's we had a we had a meeting for
those that are freshmen we had a meeting
last year on committees and commissions
in that committee and I I'm pleased to
be able to quote Mar uh representative
Smith margorie
Smith we have smart people here um we
don't need commissions we have all with
425 of us we have enough uh um brain
power here to solve almost anything and
it doesn't have to be done within the
framework of a study committee um I
think it can be
done I think it could be discussed on an
ad hoc basis now not waste the time and
um and perhaps even in September come
back with a better Bill thank you
representative way thank you um so this
is more of a general question it sounds
like there's a separate issue of the
deadlines um being really tight that
would make this infeasible so so is
there um or has there been any kind of
review of those deadlines uh in the
house you just expanded this bill um
beyond all all um now now we're talking
a constitutional Bill okay I didn't know
if that was something that was already
under review or if that's something that
would yeah be beneficial it was in 1784
you know um there's uh there's a lot of
things that we do that are
um based on the second Tuesday of the
third Wednesday beginning with T You
Know It uh it would be a much bigger
discussion uh it's really not
appropriate for the exact session unless
there's a question that somebody had but
um thank you um I think uh I see no
further questions I'm happy to uh ask
the clerk to call the rooll on U on the
I I'm sorry that's okay thank you for
the time were you waving long or is that
did I just not see you no I wasn't
waving too long I you just did that a
little fast and so I and then I started
to wave at you that's okay I'm all good
no no no problem it's not it doesn't
count as the mistake you're still it too
um uh so um I
um have felt
inspired um in some of the testimony
from the previous Bill to just State and
I'm going to start to try to do this
because this is from um the beginning of
our bill to just State um for every bill
would you believe the question I have is
that the online support for this bill
was 116 and opposition was
seven that's all thank you
I I will agree that I am remiss to uh
State those I do look at each and every
one of them um and I have the numbers
somewhere here um but I am remissed to
put it on the public record um with that
any further com question of the chair uh
we are going to vote on an itl for 157
I'm assuming we're not voting on the
amendment since it never received a
second also um
we could um if anyone would like
to we did not we introduced it we did
not
um can I make a
motion we can oh I'm getting the
on that's right there is
no it this would have the LL would have
to be voted down in order toak bring up
the amendment you can't have before the
amendment got the chance to be
introduced what's that that motion was
made before the amendment got the chance
to be introduced
correct motion was made the motion was
made itl and then we we brought up the
discussion of this you would have to
vote down the
itl and then um offer a motion of ought
to pass and then introduce the amendment
and ask for a second that would be the
procedure question on procedure question
so how we have the procedure uh person
here so yeah so I guess I was expecting
that we would have discussed the
amendment first like we did previously
for from a procedural point of view but
that was well no procedurally prior to
this we had an oop pass motion and then
and then we moved um it was open to
further Amendment and we brought in the
amendment you can have octop pass as
amended you can't have itl as amended
okay thanks
right point of parliamentary inquiry oh
okay uh Mr chair why do we have a copy
of the amendment before us if it was
there no intention to introduce it um it
was a discussion Point um it was brought
up I think actually in the original
discussion of the yeah you can point to
it all you want but I'm telling you that
it was brought up during the discussion
of the um original motion that um that
they had had a conversation and there
was an amendment so we were talking
about what was in that Amendment so yep
representative thank you Mr chair so I I
just want to make sure we're we're we're
getting this thorough because it's my
understanding that amendments could be
brought to a a committee to Executive
session that that simply don't get
picked up or or moved right it's
certainly not unprecedented that an
amendment would be on the table but
never never acted upon is that correct
um I think probably more than half of my
amendments that I brought to Executive
session were never um introduced it's a
discussion Point more than anything
thank you Mr
chair good you had your hand raised
Representative turot no you've taken it
representative Vil said exactly what I
was going to say he often does that um
yes representative way thank you Mr
chair I just want to
emphasize this amendment was was put
forward and we had intended to vote on
it and discuss it but the motion to to
itl it was the very first thing that was
said on this bill there wasn't even any
period of time for us to make a motion
to introduce the amendment and second
it I I understand that maybe at this
point we can't since the itl motion has
already been made but I just want to
make sure that future amendments get the
opportunity be to be introduced before
we immediately jump to the itl
motion um representative Ville thank you
Mr chairman um it it's my understanding
that if an itl motion is is made then
the way to get the uh Amendment brought
up is to overturn the the itl in
committee and so then because we we only
um operate by affirmative disposition
right so if you if the if the itl is
rejected then presumably the next motion
would be ought to pass and at that point
uh an amendment could be brought forward
for consideration is that correct Mr
chair I concur with representative
sirart once again you said what I should
have said in so I'm still representative
veral I think think we switched
it representative turot agreeing with
you thank
further represent Barton yes uh so if an
amendment was made that would have
improved the original bill and I never
had a chance to see it or hear it or
even entertain it um before the motion
was made because someone quickly jumped
to an itl motion which I seconded but I
I wouldn't have seen this if I would
have seen this maybe I would have
changed my mind and said no this with
this incorporated into into the bill it
would be ought to pass it doesn't make
sense uh to me to have an amendment
presented before the committee and and
not be considered because now all I
consider I can't even consider this I
can only consider the the legislation
that's be been moved before me and if I
vote itl on that and and this would have
changed my opinion if it was introduced
that opportunity is is gone so I don't
understand the procedure so um I
disagree with your your premise um you
do have the opportunity I um I allowed
um or first off the amendment was
emailed to the entire committee week ago
anyway something like that um
secondly um you still have the
opportunity to consider that um you
would just vote no on the I motion and
then the committee would be able to do
it you have it in front of you um it's
not that you can't consider it you can
motion representative W thank you Mr
chairman I wonder if the members who
made the itl motion will be willing
to withdraw that for now so we could
that seeing no further
discussion I can ask the clerk to call
the role uh on the motion of itl on
157 BL chair Sheen yes representative
turkot yes representative verville yes
representative Boyd yes clerk votes yes
representative Barton
no representative
wall representative Richards no
Representative py no representative Fox
no representative Wade no and the chair
shair votes
yes we got 6j six nay motion passes of
157 uh I don't know the vote I'm sorry
six six uh one two three four got be
seven seven no
six three four five six I guess 6 y six
6 n ah so the motion fails uh now we are
looking for another motion Mr chairman
point of order I don't know yes um is a
I thought a tie vote out of committee
was a no recommendation and so got to go
through the process fair enough thank
you Mr chairman thank you um looking for
another motion
I'd like to make a motion representative
P I'd like to make a motion on Amendment
um well first you would make the motion
of ought to pass presumably okay I would
like to make a motion of ought to pass
on house
bill7 second fine and and is that
seconded seconded seconded by
representative Wade is there um any
discussion
yes or question regarding order please M
how do we make the motion on the
amendment so it is open to you can um
further open the amendment uh you can
offer proposal um or Amendment
Z
7628 is that what that says um to House
Bill 157 so is that what you're doing
yes please okay and uh and there would
be a second seconded
okay and now you would like to discuss
Amendment 157 which I thought you
already did but I did I did already
thank you so I I think a lot of the
confusion here is like parliamentary
procedure so thank you maybe yeah the
motion second um motion
seconded and
Wade thank you thank you yeah thank you
okay so um as we went through our
uh Bill excuse me I need
lunch good
up blood sugar
um again fiscal notes are consistently a
troubling thing and we do have a lot of
study commissions um we've actually just
disassembled some today and I think
there's good representation here on this
process because fiscal notes do cause a
problem and a burden and sometimes I
always want wonder why some of these
bills even have a fiscal note um so
putting together a study committee and I
the amendment minimizes the impact of
that and simplifies it with regards to
the scope and the membership so if we
had folks that there's clearly
individuals that want to participate in
this study committee so I think that
that speaks to a lot there was a lot of
support online so why not put it through
our committee and let the house floor
decide on um moving
forward that's my thoughts
discuss um I just want to emphasize I
support this amendment because I think
it incorporates a lot of the feedback
that we got during that initial hearing
um including things like incorporating
the legislative budget assistant as a
member which I think might be more
challenging to do as an ad hoc committee
and I fully agree there are lots of
committees that might be obsolete at
this point or might not meet or have a
very narrow scope that might have been
better served by an ad hoc committee but
this is definitely a case where it's a
persistent issue that comes back year
after year and I think this amendment
does a good job at keeping the scope
reasonable and approaching this in a way
involved further discussion
representative
other than
the really the changing of the
membership and uh
removing being appointed by
chairpersons um this changes none of my
perspective on the underlying bill and
I'll reiterate for the record those
issues um one I believe the sponsors and
the co-sponsors can do this uh ad hoc
without a
formal um committee yet another study
committee being uh formed um we talked
about the time requirement the disc uh
detailed fiscal notes um the uncertainty
and subjectiveness of the expansion U
when you start expanding the scope of
these fiscal notes and uh again I will
say that I think the concept is good I I
I believe it would be very helpful to
have better fiscal
analysis I would suggest the individuals
sponsors and co-sponsors get together
and come up with the plan and a bill for
you uh
representative um wall thank you very
much um since there seems to be such
concern on both sides on this and
initially had had bipartisan sponsorship
now and this amendment also has
bipartisan uh sponsorship and support
would it make sense to retain this and
work on it uh you're you're
floor um further
discussion see representative
parliamentary um question so if if this
is a split decision then would it be
open for a motion of retain afterwards
it would it would indeed thank you Mr
chair um before we get to that point
before I ask the clerk to call the rooll
uh we're going to take a five minute
recess um we will be Republicans will be
in the in the office you can stay here
if you'd like um and we're
recessed good call Mr chair this meeting
is going longer than your schedule I
have a question about my parking meter
if we take this five minute break now
can you extend it to
10 so that I can move my car oh
certainly yeah yeah yeah I really
greatly I'm happy to do that um we'll be
back at uh between 25 p and uh 11:30 you
rock thanks thanks don't
run
e
back
um the good news is we're going to be
able to make lunch um the bad news is we
are um in recess until uh next Wednesday
at
recess